We can square r, or just use
a function in Google Sheets, RSQ,
to calculate the value of r squared.
Squaring the value of r
gives us a value of 0.9744.
Remember, the closer the data
points are to the line,
the closer the value of
r squared will be to 1.
If the value's closer to 0,
then the correlation is weak.
In our example, the equation of the line
is a great representation of the data,
and can be used to predict average
values for the number of tickets.
If we had a new customer with 600
employees, we could estimate the average
number of tickets as y = 0.1833(600)-
11.0548, which equals 98.92, or
approximately 100 tickets
per week on average.
We just created our first simple
predictive model using linear regression
and validated the result.